let's talk about climate change people
are calling it the crisis of our time
and it is five changes five times but
it's easy to get lost in this story the
science is dense and politics get in the
way world leaders are meeting in Madrid
to talk about the climate crisis and how
to slow it down and they're under
pressure from millions of people around
the world calling for concrete action
the empty promises are the same and the
inaction is the same so what exactly are
we doing wrong and how do we fix it
[Music]
we're going to kick this off with some
basic science so bear with me because
this is important look at this graph
these are the levels of carbon dioxide
in our atmosphere over hundreds of
thousands of years but this spike in
carbon dioxide at the very end that took
off during the industrial revolution
we started breaking co2 records in 1950
and we haven't stopped since
why well scientists say there's a 95%
chance that human activity is the cause
we've been burning more and more fossil
fuels like oil and coal which release
co2 to power our homes factories
airplanes and cars there's also a lot
more of us the global population has
tripled in the past 70 years and we're
consuming more products from animals
that release another pollute called
methane so all those gases are released
into the air and when sunlight gets into
the Earth's atmosphere some of the heat
gets trapped and the planet gets warmer
that's why they call it the greenhouse
effect but the concern is not that the
earth is getting warmer it's that it's
happening far too quickly but it's
actually the warmest temperature on
earth since the last ice age since
10,000 years ago the UN says that right
now our world is about one degree hotter
than pre-industrial times that's around
the Year 1800 which is okay in fact the
UN says if we warm by 1.5 degrees before
the end of the century we should be fine
the
even says two degrees would probably be
alright but again the problem is speed
because right now we're on track to hit
1.5 degrees in only 10 years and if we
don't slow that warming down it could
mean catastrophe within my lifetime and
maybe yours too
and we're already getting a taste
[Applause]
climate changes here climate change is
happening we're well into the sixth mass
extinction event Europe was partly
colder
just in the early morning hours of
Sunday millions of people are likely to
suffer Watson and food and water
shortages outrageous now in its tenth
year is a phenomena that's here to stay
we've never seen a year's worth of rain
in less than seven days sea levels are
rising about three millimeters a year
because seawater expands as temperatures
get warmer melting ice sheets and
glaciers also add trillions of tons of
fresh water into our oceans people
around the world are already losing
their homes and if things carry on
millions more of us will have to pack up
too entire coastal cities could be
underwater within 80 years like Miami in
the US or Osaka in Japan entire island
nations in the Pacific could completely
disappear that's what disasters becoming
more and more intense more frequent with
more devastating consequence the
dramatic impacts of droughts in
different parts of the world all these
is creating a situation that is a real
threat to humankind and we are not doing
enough if 99% doctor said to you take
this medicine or you will get really
thick and probably die you would take it
who wouldn't take it the problem is at
the moment we don't have any medicine
now there is a plan to slow all this
down back in 2016 world leaders signed
the so-called Paris agreement and the
big pledge is to cap temperatures rising
by 1.5 degrees or a maximum of two
before the year 2100 so countries set
their own targets on how much co2 they
emit but here's the thing three years
after the agreement global co2 levels
are still going up co2 emissions have
been going up the last year by two
percent so that's actually above the
average of the last ten years so it
started to increase again and it doesn't
look too good
in some ways we're going backwards the
United States will cease all
implementation of the non-binding Paris
Accord and the draconian financial and
economic burdens the agreement imposes
on our country the u.s. one of the
world's biggest polluters has pulled out
of the Paris deal Russia and China are
accused of not giving themselves
ambitious targets in the first place
Turkey and Poland want to build more
power plants that use coal and then
there's the skeptics it's a political
decision
today's man-made global warming who
forced the computer models to say AHA
human influence co2 and other stuff the
ground-based temperature data has been
massaged to show an increase but the
satellite data shows no increase on the
other hand there is positive momentum
there's more awareness and some
countries are making progress India
Morocco and the Gambia have massive
renewable energy projects some countries
are for example you know making public
free in cities what a great way to
encourage people out of their cause but
experts say what's needed now is an even
bigger push to change everything about
the way we run our world business as
usual has got to change politics is you
has got to change them in order to
combat that we have to change the system
that is allowed it to happen you can't
have infinite growth on a finite planet
and everyone can do that by you know
shifting to renewable energy reducing
the use of cars use train more cycle
more eat less needs consume a bit more
carefully so where does that leave us
well there's only so much bike riding
and light bulb replacing that you and I
can do every day but the truth is that
it's those everyday things that are
going to change anyway
even coffee could run out if farmers
can't grow it so the expert advice is
that it's down to all of us to change
our ways and shake things up or climate
change is gonna do it for us
if there is a story you want to get your
head around let us know get in touch
with us on Twitter or Facebook also make
sure to subscribe to our YouTube channel
so you never miss an episode